and hello again from fox news in
washington today from the white house
we're on the president's patio just
outside
the oval office president trump you've
agreed to answer all manner of questions
no subject off-limits thank you
and welcome back to fox news sunday
thank you very much let's start with the
surge
of the coronavirus across the country
in recent months you still talk about it
as quote
burning embers but i want to put up a
chart that shows
where we are with the illness over the
last four months as you can see we hit a
peak
here in april 36 000 cases it's cases
a day cases then it went down and now
since june
it has gone up more than doubled one day
this week 75 000
new cases more than double chris that's
because we have great testing because we
have the best testing in the world if we
didn't test you wouldn't be able to show
that
chart if we tested half as much those
numbers would be down but but this is
burning embers sir this is a foreign but
i don't say i say
flames we'll put out the flames and
we'll put out in some cases just
burning embers we also have burning
embers we have embers
and we do have flames florida became
more flame-like but it's
uh it's going to be under control and
you know it's not just this country it's
many countries we don't talk about it in
the news they don't talk about mexico
and brazil
and still parts of europe which actually
got hit sooner than us so it's a little
ahead of us in that sense
but you take a look why don't they talk
about mexico
which is not helping us and all i can
say is thank god i build most of the
wall because if i didn't have the wall
up
we would have a much bigger problem with
mexico but sir we have the seventh
highest mortality rate in the world our
mortality rate is higher than brazil
it's higher than russia and the european
union has us on a travel ban yeah i
think what we'll do well we have them in
a travel ban too chris i closed them off
if you remember i was the one that did
the european union very early but when
you talk about mortality rates
i think it's the opposite i think we
have one of the lowest mortality rates
we had 900 deaths in a single day we
will take
this week ready do you please get me the
mortality right yeah
kaylee's right here i heard we have one
of the lowest maybe the lowest mortality
rate anywhere in the world
you have the numbers please because i
heard we had the best mortality right
number number one low mortality right i
hope you show the scenario because it
shows what fake news is all about
you said we had the worst mortality rate
in the world and we have the best
all right it's a little complicated but
bear with us
we went with numbers from johns hopkins
university which charted the mortality
rate for 20 countries hit by the virus
the u.s
ranked seventh better than the united
kingdom but worse than brazil and russia
the white house went
with this chart from the european cdc
which shows italy and spain doing worse
but countries like brazil and south
korea
doing better other countries doing
better like russia
aren't included in the white house
charge california
locking down again florida deadliest day
of the entire pandemic
uh hospitals at capacity a number of
places around the country
shortages of testing shortages of
personal protective equipment for nurses
and doctors
a lot of people say this is because we
don't have a national
plan you talk about states we don't have
a national plan do you take
responsibility for that
look i take responsibility always for
everything because
it's ultimately my job too i have to get
everybody in line
some governors have done well some
governors have done poorly
they're supposed to have supplies they
didn't have i supplied everybody
now we have somewhat of a surge in
certain areas and other areas we're
doing great
but we have a surge in certain areas but
you don't hear people complaining about
ventilators we've got all the
ventilators we can use we're supplying
them to other countries
we go out into parking lots and
everything everybody gets a test
we find if we did half the testing with
all of that being said
i'm glad we did it this is the right way
to do it
i'm glad we did what we're doing but we
have more tests by far
than any country in the world but sir
testing is up 37
well that's very good i understand cases
are up
194 it isn't just the testing has gone
up
it's that the virus has spread the
positivity rate has increased
there are many of those cases many of
those cases are young people that would
heal
in a day they have the sniffles and we
put it down as a test
many of them don't forget i guess it's
like 99.7 percent
people are going to get better and in
many cases they're going to get better
very quickly
we go out and we look and then on the
news look if you go back to the news all
of your even your wonderful competitors
you'll see cases are up well cases are
up many of those cases
shouldn't even be cases cases are up
because we have the best
testing in the world and we have the
most tested no country has ever done
what we've done
in terms of testing we are the envy of
the world they call
and they say the most incredible job
anybody's done
is our job on testing because we're
going to very shortly be up to 50
million tests
you look at other countries they don't
even do tests they do test if somebody
walks into the hospital
they're sick they're really sick they
test them then
or they'll test them in a doctor's
office but they don't go around have
massive areas of testing and we do
and i'm glad we do but it really skews
the numbers
i'm going to do you a favor because i'm
sure a lot of people listening right now
are going to say trump he tries to play
it down
he tries to make it not seem as serious
as it is
75 000 cases a day show me the death
chart
well i don't have the doubt
the death chart is a thousand cases a
day excuse me
it's all too much it shouldn't be one
case it came from china they should have
never let it escape
they should have never let it out but it
is what it is
take a look at europe take a look at the
numbers in europe and by the way they're
having surgeries
are 6 000 in the whole european union
they don't test
they don't test like it's impossible
that they don't have the viruses badly
it's possible that they don't test
that's what's possible we find cases and
many of those cases
heal automatically we're finding in a
way we're creating trouble
certainly we're creating trouble for the
fake news to come along and say
oh we have more cases look we did
something that nobody's ever done not
only the ventilators where we're
supplying them all over the world
we did a testing program the likes of
which nobody's ever done before
the head of the cdc dr redfield said
this on tuesday
i do think the fall and the winter of
2020 and 2021 are going to be
probably one of the most difficult times
that we've experienced
in american public health do you agree
with dr redfield
i don't know and i don't think he knows
i don't think anybody knows with this
this is a very tricky
deal everybody thought the summer it
would go away and we'd come back in the
fall
well in the summer it came they used to
say the heat the heat was good for it
and
it really knocks it out remember and
then it might come back in the fall
so they got that one wrong they they got
a lot wrong they got a lot wrong the
world health got a tremendous amount
wrong
they basically did whatever china wanted
them to
and will save now almost 500 million
dollars a year which is nice
but the world health got a lot wrong but
this is one of the sharpest criticisms
of you i agree
people say that you talk about
the world as you'd like to see it rather
than follow the science no
well let me let me just ask the question
sir
why on earth would your administration
be involved in a campaign at this point
to discredit
dr fauci who is the nation's top
infectious disease expert
because we're not if one man from my
administration
doesn't like him because he made a few
mistakes look dr fauci said don't wear a
mask
dr fauci told me not to ban china it
would be a big mistake i did it
over and above his recommendation dr
fauci then said you saved
tens of thousands of lives more than
that he said you saved tens of thousands
of lives
dr fauci has made some mistakes but i
have a very good i spoke to him
yesterday at length i have a very good
relationship with dr fatcher
but sir this week this weekend your
white house put out a series of
statements so-called mistakes
that dr fauci has had made one of your
closest aides one of your right-hand men
daniel's daniel scavina
put out this have you seen this
dr dr fawcett who shows him as a leaker
and an alarmist oh i don't know that
he's a little why he's a little bit of
an armist that's okay
a little bit i'm going to learn a little
bit of an alarm system
let me just say dr fauci at the
beginning
and again i have a great relationship
with him i spoke to him at length
yesterday
dr fauci at the beginning said this will
pass don't worry about it this will pass
he was wrong
dr fauci said don't ban china don't ban
china
i did he then admitted that i was right
you made mistakes too
i guess everybody makes i was gonna say
you said at one point
it's one person coming in from china
and we have it under control it's going
to be just fine
when you have 15 people and the 15
within a couple of days is going to be
down to close to zero
that's a pretty good job we've done i
think we're going to be very good with
the
coronavirus i think that at some point
uh that's going to sort of
just disappear i hope i'll be right
eventually i will be right
eventually you know i said it's going to
disappear i'll say it again but it's
going to disappear
and i'll be right i don't think so right
i don't think so you know why it doesn't
describe it because i've been right
probably more than anybody else
then there are masks from the first day
that the cdc
said that people should wear mass on
april 3rd you said
you weren't going to you wore a mask for
the first time in public
at walter reed this weekend question the
cdc
says if everybody wore a mask for four
to six weeks we could get this under
control
do you regret not wearing a mask in
public from the start
and would you consider will you consider
a national mandate that people need to
wear masks no i want people to have a
certain freedom
and i don't believe in that no and i
don't agree with the statement that if
everybody wear a mask everything
disappears hey dr fauci said don't wear
a mask
our surgeon general terrific guy said
don't wear a mask everybody was saying
don't wear a mask all of a sudden
everybody's got to wear a mask
and as you know masks cause problems too
with that being said
i'm a believer in masks i think masks
are good but
i leave it up to the governors many of
the governors are changing they're more
masked into they like the concept of
masks
but some of them don't agree i do say
this
schools have to open young people have
to go to school
and there's problems when you don't go
to school too and there's going to be a
funding problem because we're not going
to fund
when they don't open their schools we're
not going to fund them we're not going
to give them money
if they're not going to school if they
don't open two points on that
first of all what the federal government
gives is only
is eight percent ten percent and you
know what uh that's a lot of money
and you're going to take them you know
where the money goes it goes
overwhelmingly
to disadvantaged kids and children with
disabilities
let this i wouldn't just put send more
money so that schools be safer let the
schools open did you ever see the
statistics on young people below the age
of 18
the state of new jersey had thousands of
deaths of all of these thousands
one person below the age of 18 in the
entire state
one person and that was a person that
had i believe he said diabetes
one person below the age of 18 died in
the state of new jersey during all of
this you know they had a hard time
and they're doing very well now so
that's
it the stimulus bill is running out the
end of this month
the republicans say they want liability
limits
which the democrats don't like you say
that you want a payroll tax cut
which even some republicans are cool to
well a lot of republicans like it will
you
only sign a bill that has those two
provisions well we're going to see but
we do need protections because
businesses are going to get sued just
because somebody walked in you don't
know where this virus comes from they'll
sit down at a restaurant they'll sue the
restaurant the guy's out of business
so we do need some kind of a you know
immunity
you do need it just like you need
immunity for the police okay whether
they like it or not you need immunity
for the police
but they do need a form of immunity you
don't know if they caught it and
nobody's ever going to be able to prove
it one way or the other you can't put
these
you know the people out look the
democrats don't want to do that because
they're total
they're totally captured by the lobby of
lawyers
the lawyers lobby is probably the most
powerful in the country what about the
payroll tax cut
uh i want to see it i want to see if
it's win the bill
uh i'll have to see but yeah i would
consider not signing it if we don't have
a payroll tax cut yes
hot enough that you're here mr president
it's hot it's about uh
well sort of almost record-breaking you
know we wanted to do it inside this was
your choice
but i wanted you to sweat a little bit
well we both are
there has been a spike in violent crime
in america
in recent weeks we've seen deaths
up in new york deaths up in chicago
shootings
how do you explain it and what are you
going to do about it i explain it very
simply by saying that they're
democrat-run cities they're
liberally run they're stupidly run we
have
forced them in seattle to end the chop
because you know we were going in that
following day you probably have heard it
we were getting ready to go in we were
all set
and when they heard that we were going
they set their police force liberal
democrats have been running cities in
this country for decades poorly
why is it so bad right now uh they've
run them poorly it was always bad but
now it's gotten
totally out of control and it's really
because they want to defund the police
and biden wants to fun
sir he does not look he signed a charter
with bernie sanders i will get that one
just like i was right on the mortality
rate
did you read the charter that he agreed
there's nothing about the funding
oh really it says abolish it says let's
go
all right let me give me the charter
please all right chris you've got to
start studying for this
he says defund the police he says
defund the police they talk about
abolishing the police
they talk about illegal aliens i look
forward to seeing that meanwhile the
george floyd
murder has reignited the issue of racism
in policing in this country i want to
give you a couple of statistics
nationwide blacks are twice as likely
fewer in absolute numbers but in terms
of per capita
blacks are twice as likely to be shot
and killed by police as whites are
in minneapolis over the last five years
police used force against blacks
at a rate seven times that against
whites
can you understand why blacks would be
angry at that of course i do
of course they do many whites are killed
also you have to say that i mean
many many whites are killed i hate the
sound but this is going on
for decades this is going on for a long
time long before i got here
you know if you look at what's going on
in portland those are anarchists and
we've taken a very tough stand
if we didn't take a stand in portland
you know we've arrested many of these
leaders
if we didn't take that stand right now
you would have a problem like
you they were going to lose portland so
let's see what this says here
prosecution sanctuary cities incentivize
illegal alien expand
asylum abolish immigration detention
no that's not what we'll find okay this
thing is many pages long
end prosecution of illegal border
crosses
support deathly and these are the worst
things
i'm not disagreeing with you on any of
those i'm disagreeing about defund
police
the white house never sent us evidence
the bernie biden platform
calls for defunding or abolishing police
because
there is none it calls for increased
funding for police departments that meet
certain standards
biden has called for redirecting some
police funding
for related programs like mental health
counseling
this week you said that black lives
matter and the confederate flag are both
matters issues of freedom of speech
but in the case of the confederate flag
there are a lot of people who say these
were traitors
who split from this country fought this
country in large part
to preserve slavery is the confederate
flag
offensive it depends on who you're
talking about when you're talking about
when people proudly have their
confederate flags they're not talking
about racism they love their flag it
represents the south
they like the south people right now
like the south i say it's
freedom of of many things but it's
freedom of speech so you're not offended
by it well
i'm not offended either by black lives
matter that's freedom of speech
and you know the whole thing with
canceled culture we can't cancel our
whole history we can't forget that the
north
and the south fought we have to remember
that otherwise we'll end up fighting
again
you can't you can't just cancel all this
but let me ask you this when it gets to
be more than just cancel
well maybe this is cancelled culture the
national defense authorization act the
ndaa you have threatened to veto it
because in the bill and this is
supported by republicans as well as
democrats it would rename
army bases named for confederate
generals now this is a bill that funds
military operations it gives soldiers a
pay raise
you're going to veto that because
they'll get their pay raise hey look
don't tell me this
i got soldiers the biggest pay raises in
the history of our understood
of our military i got soldiers brand new
equipment brand new jets brand new
rockets brand new 2.5 trillion i did
more for the military
than any president that's ever had this
because i think that fort bragg fought
robert and lee all of these forts that
have been named that way for
a long time decades and decades the
military says they're for that
excuse me i don't care what the military
says i do i'm supposed to make the
decision
fort bragg is a big deal we won two
world wars nobody even knows general
bragg
we won two world wars go to that
community where fort bragg is in a great
state i love that state
go to go to the community say how do you
like the idea
of renaming fort bragg and
then what are we going to name it you're
going to name it after the reverend al
sharpton
what are you going to name it chris tell
me what you're going to name it
so there's a whole thing here we won two
world
wars two world wars beautiful world wars
that were vicious and horrible and we
want them out of fort bragg
we want to out of all of these forts
that now
they want to throw those names away and
no i'm against that
and you know what most other people are
and i even i don't believe in polls
because i
see the fakest polls i've ever seen but
that poll is a 64
thing which actually surprised me we won
world wars
out of these out of these military bases
no i'm not going to go changing them
i'm not going to say you'll be each of
them i might yeah i might
at mount rushmore on july 3rd you said
that we face a
far left fascism in this country and
then you said this
our children are taught in school
to hate their own country and to believe
that the men and women who built it were
not heroes but that were
villains you said our children are
taught in school
to hate our country where do you see
that i just
look at i look at school i watch i read
look at the stuff now they want to
change if
1492 columbus discovered america you
know we grew up you grew up we all did
that's what we learned now they want to
make it the 1619 project where did that
come from
what does it represent i don't even know
so slavery
that's what they're saying but they
don't even know they just want to make a
change
cancel culture i hate the term actually
but i use it better they
cancel people hate i think so yeah i
think so
look at the professors look at what's
going on in the colleges if a
conservative goes on a college and look
we have as many as them
excuse me i think to the best of my
knowledge we're sitting at the white
house
and the oval office is right behind me
we have as many as them
but who's them the
liberal radical left and i'm not talking
all i think liberal i
i could tell you i like a lot of liberal
people like
like a lot of liberal governors and
senators but but chris
we have a radical left destructive
ideology and it's
being taught in our schools and don't
act like you're surprised to hear this
there are books written about it and we
can't let that go on
we can't let them change the true
meaning of what we're all about
and that's what they're trying to do and
i don't want it to happen not on
my watch it's not going to happen on my
watch mr president you'll be happy to
know that fox news has a new poll
out today and you're going to be the
very first person to hear about it
in the national horse race joe biden
leads you by eight points
49 to 41 that's i think three four
points slimmer
than it was a month ago and on the
issues people trust
biden more to handle the coronavirus by
17 points on race relations by 21 points
and even on the economy they trust biden
moore by one point
i understand we still have more than a
hundred days to this election but at
this point
you're losing first of all i'm not
losing
because those are fake polls they were
fake in 2016
and now they're even more fake the polls
were much worse in 2016.
they interview 22 percent republican
well how do you do 22
republican you see what's going on uh i
have other polls that put me
leading and we have polls where i'm
leading i have a poll where we're
leading in every swing state
and i don't believe that you're first of
all the fox polls whoever does your fox
polls they're among the worst they got
it all wrong in 2016.
they've been wrong on every poll i've
ever seen i must tell you no i'm just
telling you
and and let me let me ask you this so in
the economy so i've always lead on the
economy
by a lot i know which is why i would
like to put two sentences together
they wheel them out he goes up he
repeats he they ask him questions he
reads a teleprompter and then he goes
back into his basement
you tell me the american people want to
have that in an age where we're
in trouble with other nations that are
looking to do numbers on us so let me
ask you a direct question no i'm going
to ask you a direct question about joe
biden
is joe biden senile i don't want to say
that i say he's not competent
to be president to be president you have
to be sharp
and tough and so many other things
he doesn't even come out of his basement
they think oh this is a great campaign
so he goes in i'll then make a speech
it'll be a great speech
and some young guys start writing vice
president biden said this this this
he didn't say it joe doesn't know he's
alive okay he doesn't know he's alive
do the american people want that number
one number two i built the greatest
economy ever built anywhere in the world
not only in this country anywhere in the
world
until we got hit with the china virus we
got hit with a virus shouldn't have
happened
and we had to close up we saved millions
of lives now we've opened it up
got to go back to school we're open
we've got to do things we had the best
job numbers we've ever had last month we
should have good ones coming up
in two weeks look i built the greatest
economy in history
i'm now doing it again you see the
numbers the numbers are through the roof
the democrats are purposely keeping
their schools close
keeping their states close i call to
michigan i want to have a big rally in
michigan
do you know we're not allowed to have a
rally in michigan do you know we're not
allowed to have a rally in minnesota do
you know we're not allowed to have a
rally in
nevada we're not allowed to have rallies
well and these democrat
run statements some people would say
that that's a health risk some people
would say it's fine
i mean but i guarantee you there's some
issues after time everything was gone
100
they still wouldn't allow it they're not
allowing me to do it
so they're not that they're not allowing
me to have rallies but i got to tell you
if i may sir respectfully in the fox
poll they ask people
who is more competent who's got whose
mind is sounder
biden beats you in that well i tell you
what uh let's take a test
let's take a test right now let's go
down joe and i will take a test
let him take the same test that i took
incidentally i took the test too when i
heard that you passed it yeah how did
you do it
well it's not the hardest task no but it
has a picture and it says
that and it's an element no no no you
see that's all misrepresentation that's
what it was on the web
it's all misrepresentation because yes
the first few questions are easy
but i'll bet you couldn't even answer
the last five questions i'll bet you
couldn't they get very hard the last
five well one of them was count back
from 100 by seven
and let me tell you you couldn't answer
you couldn't answer all right what's the
question many of the questions i'd get
you the test i'd like to give it
but i guarantee you that joe biden could
not answer those questions
okay and i answered all 35 questions
correctly you you
talk about how you're winning campaign's
going well
why did you replace brad parscale isn't
that because he's a great
digital guy uh we all like him a lot
but i have somebody that i that was
involved you know they're all they were
all on the 2016 campaign
and we have cory and we have all the
people and actually steve bannon's been
much better not being involved he says
the greatest president ever i mean he's
saying things that i said
let's keep steve out there he's doing a
good job but they're all being they're
all involved if joe biden got in first
of all he won't call the shots
the people the radical left people that
surround him will call
religion will be gone okay
life you could forget about that the
whole question of life
supreme when you say life you mean
abortion absolutely
a hundred percent that whole question
which is a very you know it's always
been a 50 50
thing it's actually trending a little
bit more toward
once religion is going to be gone what
does that mean look at what they're
doing to the churches
they won't let the churches even open if
they want to stand in a field
six feet apart we've had churches that
wanted to stand in fields
six feet apart there has never been an
administration
that's done so much as i have from
tax cuts to regulation cuts to
rebuilding the military
to getting choice for the vets nobody's
done the things i've done
nobody in three and a half years no
other president has been able to do what
i've done
you're running in large part on the
economy you've built it
once now we have the coronavirus you're
going to build it again and in fact you
had great jobs numbers in may
you had solid jobs numbers in june but i
want you to look at some projections
the nonpartisan congressional budget
office says the unemployment rate
at the end of the year will be ten and a
half percent
jp morgan says in the fourth quarter gdp
will contract
by 6.2 percent with states now
rolling back some of the reopening and
and
well there are a lot of republicans
there are a lot of republican states
like texas but here's they'll be open
very soon just ask my question there's
no reason for california to do
to be doing what they're doing all right
except for november 3rd
with the states shutting back the
reopening in a lot of
cases new lockdowns won't the economy
still be a problem for you on elections
i don't think so i think the economy
is expanding and growing beautifully now
the democrats want to keep it closed as
long as possible because they think
that's good for election
but i think the economy is doing very
well now we're coming back
and we're coming back at a level that
nobody would have thought possible
and we and by the way take a look at
another i mean a gauge whether you like
it or not
the stock market the stock market nasdaq
hit its all-time
high two weeks ago and it's beaten at 14
different times okay
the stock market dow etc is
a thousand points away from its all-time
high meaning very close
we're going to have a stock market
perhaps on november
3rd that's the highest in history i want
to talk to you about obamacare
since the pandemic hit millions of
people have lost their jobs
and thereby lost their health insurance
and almost a half a million have signed
up for obamacare
your administration just announced that
you're signing on to a lawsuit
to overturn obamacare and replace it
why does it make sense to overturn
obamacare
which people now are relying on
democrats are going to say
the man who's wanted to kill obamacare
is going to take away the protection for
pre-existing conditions first of all we
got rid of the individual mandate
pre-existing conditions will always be
taken care of by me and republicans 100
but you've been in the office three and
a half years you don't have people we
haven't had
uh excuse me you heard me yesterday
we're signing a health care plan
within two weeks a full and complete
health care plan
that the supreme court decision on daca
gave me the right to do
so we're gonna solve we're gonna sign an
immigration plan
a health care plan and various other
plans
and nobody will have done what i'm doing
in the next four weeks
the supreme court gave the president of
the united states
powers that nobody thought the president
had by approving by doing what they did
their decision on daca
and daca is going to be taken care of
also but we're getting rid of it because
we're going to replace it with something
much better
but we got rid of already which was most
of obamacare the individual mandate
and that i've already won on and we won
also on the supreme court
but the decision by the supreme court on
daca
allows me to do things on immigration on
health care on other things
that we've never done before and you're
going to find it to be a very exciting
two weeks
your niece mary trump has written a book
about you
and your family and one of her main
points is that she says your dad
fred trump senior damaged the whole
family
and here's what she says about what you
learned from your father
he learned to become the killer you
mentioned
the man who needs to
succeed at all costs who
will do anything um
to get attention financial rewards
and to win do you see any truth in that
my father liked to win my father was a
very good man he was a strong man
it's disgraceful that she said that she
was not exactly a family favorite we
didn't
have a lot of respect or like for her i
would have never said that except she
writes a book that's so stupid and so
vicious
and it's a lie my father was a great
wonderful man
let me just ask you this question this
is not a person that i spent
very much time with very little time and
now i'm glad
you've developed a pretty thick skin
over the years from decades of attacks
in new york tabloids now from
the press here and your political
opponents here in washington
but even for donald trump does it hurt
you at all
to be attacked in such personal terms by
a member of your own family
uh it hurts me more about attacking my
father
not being kind to my mother i have a
mother who was like a saint
she was incredible she was an incredible
woman
and she was nasty even to my mother
she's a very scarred person she was not
much of a family person but look let me
just tell you
my father was i think he was the most
solid person
i've ever met and he was a very good
person he was a very very good person he
was strong but he was good
for her to say the kind of things a
psychopath that he was a psychopath
anybody that knew fred trump would call
him a psychopath and you know what
if he was i would tell you and i would
say you know chris i was with my father
and it was impossible
my father was he was tough he was tough
on me he was tough on all of the kids
but tough in a in a solid sense in a
really good sense for her to say i think
the word she used was psychopath
what a disgrace she ought to be ashamed
of herself that book is a lie
some people were surprised when you
agreed to this interview to sit down
with me
what are you going to ask especially
because of some of the mean tweets
that you've said about me mike wallace
wanna be nasty and obnoxious
i will tell you after that one my son
peter who you've met
called and he said nasty no obnoxious
maybe
but here's the question one of your beef
seems to be
that i put democrats on the show and i
ask them questions
and and i guess the question i have is
don't you understand it's my job
to put democrats on as well as
republicans and to ask them probing
questions just like i asked republicans
i'm not a big fan of fox i'll be honest
with you they've changed a lot since
roger ailes
and i watch people like swalwell who i
don't even know he goes on the show
he got less than one percent all of a
sudden he's on being interviewed for
endless yeah but i i interviewed an
answer wait i interviewed nancy
i answered i uh interviewed using one
tweet after i interviewed nancy pelosi
and in the interview i asked her
specifically about the fact in february
you were in chinatown pitching tourism
while the virus was spreading if the
president underplayed the threat in the
early days
speaker pelosi didn't you as well
isn't that legitimate to talk to the
speaker of the house look i know you
very well i respect you a lot i respect
your father a lot i thought he's one of
the most talented journalists
there are and you likewise are a very
talented person
i do think this i think you are very uh
uh i think you are toward the democrat
side which is okay
i mean it's not true if watch the james
comey interview i did in december
17 significant errors in the fisa
process
and you say that it was handled in a
thoughtful and appropriate way
yeah he's right i was wrong but you make
it sound like you're a
a bystander an eyewitness you were the
director of the fbi well a lot of this
was going on sir
sure i'm responsible for that's why i'm
telling you i was wrong i was
overconfident as director
in our procedures you couldn't do as
tough an interview with comey i
i'd like to think i treat everybody the
same it just seems to me that you are
very prone to be
nice to the democrats and maybe i'm
wrong about that chris but it's an honor
to be with you
it's fine i love it i love it that it's
close to 100 degrees
your choice again yeah i know that so
i'm not
saying you're going to lose i am not
saying that we saw how you turned it
around last
time i don't think i'm going to lose at
all but if you did
how crushing would it be first of all
let me just tell you something i know
everyone wants to know that because
they'd love to see me lose fine
i'm not i have not seen that i've been
written off do you know how many times
i've
been i'm not doing it this time
don't don't do it because but how
crushing would it be and you know why i
won't lose because the country in the
end
they're not going to have a man who
who's
shot he's shot he's mentally shot let
him come out of his basement go around
i'll make four or five speeches a day
i'll be interviewed by you i'll be
interviewed by the worst killers that
hate my
my guts they hate my guts there's
nothing they can ask me
that i won't give them a proper answer
to some people will like it some people
won't like i agree with that but look
you answered let biden sit through an
interview like this
he'll be on the ground crying for mommy
he'll say mommy mommy please take me
home well we've asked him for an
interview sir
he can't do an interview he's
incompetent there's a number you don't
mention
it's called the enthusiasm number the
enthusiasm for trump is through the roof
i haven't mentioned it even higher than
last time
the enthusiasm for biden is non-existent
everyone knows each other but the
enthusiasm against you
okay that's his only shot right that's
his only shot i agree
and those people know i'm doing a good
job but there's something in my
personality that they don't like because
look
nobody's done what i've done biden wants
to come in
and ruin our country triple your taxes
he wants to do things he wants to add
regulations that i've all cut
and we still have regulation a lot of
regulation but i've cut it down to a
level that nobody's
nobody ever thought possible he will
destroy this country
but it won't be him it will be the
radical left
the same type ideology that took over
venezuela
one of the richest countries in the
world they now have no water they have
no food
and they have no medicine that's going
to happen two final questions a few wins
in general not talking about november
are you a good loser
i'm not a good loser i don't like to
lose it i don't lose too often
i don't like something but are you
gracious you don't know until you see it
depends i think
mail-in voting is is going to rig the
election i really do
uh are you suggesting that you might not
accept the results of the election i
have to say
look hillary clinton asked me the same
thing no i asked you the same thing in
the debate
there is a tradition in this country in
fact one of the prize of this country
is the peaceful transition of power and
that no matter how hard fought a
campaign
is that at the end of the campaign that
the loser concedes to the winner not
saying that you're necessarily going to
be the loser or the winner but that the
loser concedes to the winner
and that the country comes together in
part for the good of the country
are you saying you're not prepared now
what i'm saying is that i will tell you
at the time i'll keep you in suspense
well chris and you know what she's the
one
that never accepted her great she never
accepted her loss and she looks like can
you give
can you give a direct answer you will
accept the election
look you i have to see no i'm not going
to just say yes i'm not going to say you
know and i didn't last time either
whether it's in 2021 or 2025
how will you regard your years as
president of the united states
i think i was very unfairly treated uh
from before i even won
i was under investigation by a bunch of
thieves crooks
it was an illegal investigation but what
about the russia what about the good
parts there no i want to know this
i have done more than any president in
history in the first three and a half
years and i've done it
suffering through investigations where
people have been general flynn where
people have been so unfairly treated
the russia hoax it was all a hoax the
mueller scam it was all a scam it was
all false
i made a bad decision on one bad
decision
jeff sessions and now i feel good
because he lost overwhelmingly in the
great state of alabama
here's the bottom line i've been very
unfairly treated and i don't say that as
paranoid
i've been very everybody says it it's
going to be interesting to see what
happens but there's tremendous
evidence right now as to how unfairly
treated i was
president obama and biden spied on my
campaign
it's never happened in history if it
were the other way around
the people would be in jail for 50 years
right now that would be comey
that would be brennan that would be all
of this the two lovers
strzok and paige they would be in jail
now for many many years
they would be in jail it would have
started two years ago and they'd be
there for 50 years
the fact is they illegally spied on my
campaign
let's see what happens despite that i
did more than any president
in history in the first three and a half
years
mr president thank you thanks for
talking with us thank you
thank you very much